SO WHAT DID HAPPEN THIS WEEK
THE MEDIA ALMOST GOING ON WITH
THE REPUBLICAN NARRATIVE THAT
NEARLY EVERYONE EXPECTED AND
WANTED THE MID- TERMS ARE A
REPUDIATION OF THE GOP.
OF COURSE MANY INDIVIDUAL
RACES HAVE A DISAPPOINTING
OUTCOME BUT OVERALL
REPUBLICANS WON THE NATIONAL
POPULAR VOTE
52 PERCENT.
THAT IS A BIGGER MARGIN THAN
BIDEN TRUMP AND OBAMA MARGIN
OF VICTORY AND IN FACT ROUGHLY
THE SAME IN 2010 -┘- 2010
GAINING OVER 60 SEATS
75 PERCENT OF VOTERS YET
SOMEHOW THIS IS BEING
INTERPRETED AS A GREEN LIGHT
TO GO FURTHER AND FASTER IN
THE SAME DIRECTION OF THE FAR
LEFT.
>> QUITE IN THE NEXT TWO YEARS
DO YOU INTEND TO DO
DIFFERENTLY TO CHANGE PEOPLE'S
DIRECTION OF THE COUNTRY?
>> NOTHING.
IT'S ALL GOOD THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE GOING WITH?
ABOUT THE MENTORING CRISIS?
WHAT WOULD YOU ABOUT THE
ENERGY CRISIS?
>> NOTHING.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE CRIME WAVE
THEY UNLEASHED?
>> NOTHING.
STEVE: INFLATION?
STEVE: COLLAPSING LABOR PARTY
PARTICIPATION?
>> NOTHING.
STEVE: STANDARDS IN SCHOOLS
AND RESTORING OUR REPUTATION
INTERNATIONALLY?
>> NOTHING.
NOTHING.
NOTHING I WILL NOT CHANGE
ANYTHING.
STEVE: HE WILL CHANGE AND A
FUNDAMENTAL WAY FOR DEMOCRATS
AND POLICY A GREEN NIGHT FOR A
SECOND TERM BUT AGAIN THE EXIT
POLLS SHOW THAT ISN'T TRUE.
70 PERCENT OF VOTERS SAID THEY
DON'T WANT BIDEN TO RUN AGAIN.
>> TWO THIRDS OF AMERICANS SAY
THEY DON'T THANK YOU SHOULD
RUN FOR REELECTION.
WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE AND HOW
DOES THAT FACTOR INTO YOUR
FINAL DECISION WHETHER OR NOT
TO RUN FOR REELECTION QUICK.
>> IT DOESN'T.
>> WATCH ME.
>> WE HAVE BEEN THERE'S ONLY
SO MUCH MORE OF THIS THAT
AMERICANS CAN TAKE.
>> IT IS PASSED I GOT THAT
PAST.
>> IT WAS ALSO, LIZ BIRTHDAY
ONE -┘- KAMALA HARRIS
BIRTHDAY.
>> START OFF WITH MADE IN
AMERICA.
>> THIS IS NOT A JOKE THAT'S
WHEN THEY TRIED TO DO IT IN
2018 WITH 54 STATES.
WHAT AM I DOING HERE QUICK.
>> CHUCK SCHUMER CALLS THEM A
VINDICATION AND A REJECTION OF
ANTI- DEMOCRATIC EXTREMIST I
DON'T KNOW WHAT KIND OF
VINDICATION BUT WE RUN THE
COUNTRY BASED ON ELECTIONS NOT
EXIT POLLS.
IN THE 2010 MIDTERMS VOTERS
DISAPPROVED OF PRESIDENT OBAMA
BACKING THE OPPOSITION PARTY
BACKING BY 40 POINTS AND IN
2018 THEY SOMEWHAT DISAPPROVED
OF PRESIDENT TRUMP GO BACK TO
DEMOCRATS BY 30 POINTS BUT
THIS TIME IF THEY DISAPPROVED
OF BIDEN STILL BACKED HIM BY
FOUR POINTS.
HOW COME?
BECAUSE THE TRIED AND TESTED
RESPONSE OF ANY PARTY LIKE
DEMOCRATS TODAY HAVE A
TERRIBLE RECORD ON A HOPELESS
LEADER TO ATTACK THE OTHER
SIDE.
THEY SAY THEY HATE NEGATIVE
CAMPAIGNING BUT IT WORKS.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE TO PUT UP
WITH THIS GARBAGE.
>> DEMOCRACY IS AT RISK IN
UNDER THREAT.
THE EXTREME REPUBLICAN PARTY
ELEMENT TRYING TO SUCCEED
WHERE THEY FEED ON -┘- FAILED
IN 2020.
SUPPRESS THE RIGHT OF VOTERS
AND SUBVERT THE ELECTORAL
SYSTEM ITSELF.
>> AMERICAN DEMOCRACY WHICH IS
NOW 233 YEARS OLD AND MIGHT BE
IN THE FINAL YEAR OF LIFE.
BECAUSE WITH NEXT WEEK'S
ELECTION DEMOCRACY AS WE KNOW
IT MAY NOT SURVIVE.
>> DEMOCRACY AS WE KNOW IT MAY
NOT SURVIVE THAT IS NOT AN
EXAGGERATION BUT A FACT.
>> THAT IS A LIE BUT IT
WORKS.
ONE PARTY TOOK CONTROL BUT YOU
DON'T HAVE TO MAKE THEIR JOB
EASIER.
AND THAT YOUTHFUL IS MUCH
HIGHER THAN NORMAL.
AND WITH THE NATIONWIDE BAN ON
ABORTION WHAT GAVE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY THAT?
LINDSEY GRAHAM FEDERAL
ABORTION BILL WHICH CAME OUT
OF NOWHERE AT THE REQUEST OF
ABSOLUTELY NO ONE.
HE MEANT TO HELP.
BUT HONESTLY THE SINGLE MOST
STUPID POLITICAL INITIATIVE I
HAVE EVER SEEN.
NOW IN NEVADA THE SENATE WILL
STAY IN DEMOCRATIC HANDS SO
NOW MITCH MCCONNELL'S DECISION
TO PUT MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
INTERVENE IN THE ALASKA OF
SENATE RACE WAS MORE RECKLESS
AND IRRESPONSIBLE.
TONIGHT IT IS NOT AT ALL CLEAR
AND CONTROL THE HOUSE AS WELL
THE REPUBLICANS THANKS TO
REDISTRICTING AND HELD BY THE
STRONG CAMPAIGNS OF GOVERNOR
FOR UNDERSTAND THIS IN FACT I
SAY THE CAMPAIGN EVEN THOUGH
HE DIDN'T WIN IS THE BIGGEST
HIGHLIGHT.
CUT THAT LEAD FROM 20 POINTS
AS A REMARKABLE ACHIEVEMENT.
DON'T FORGET CALIFORNIA MAY BE
REPUBLICAN SEE TO PUT THE GOP
OVER THE TOP OF HOUSE
CONTROL.
AND AN IMPORTANT LESSON THERE
OVER A DECADE AGO.
MOVEMENT TO REPLACE THE SYSTEM
THE PARTISAN GERRYMANDERING OF
THE INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING
PROCESS.
OF COURSE IT'S A COMPLETE
SCANDAL WE DON'T KNOW WHO
CONTROLS THE HOUSE WE'LL HAVE
MORE LATER IN THE SHOW.
BUT NOW WE KNOW TO LOOK
AHEAD.
IN "THE NEW YORK TIMES" IT WAS
POINTED OUT THAT DESPITE ALL
OF THE POLITICAL DRAMA AND
EVENLY DIVIDED COUNTRY NEITHER
PARTY HAS MADE BIG GAINS ARE
SUFFERED BIG LOSSES IN ANY
ELECTION.
HIS ARGUMENT THIS IS UNUSUAL
IN AMERICAN POLITICS AND WE
ARE RIPE FOR A NEW ERA WHEN
ONE PARTY DOES ACHIEVE REAL
DOMINANCE.
I THINK THE OPPORTUNITY IS THE
GREATEST FOR US BECAUSE MOST
DON'T WANT THAT FAR LEFT
MADNESS OR SELF-RIGHTEOUS
VIRTUE SIGNALING.
AND DON'T WANT IT AND
MAINSTREAM FLEXIBLE MAJORITY
PRACTICAL SOLUTIONS IN
FOUNDATION RESPIRATIONS.
BUT WE NEED TO RETHINK HOW WE
GO ABOUT THIS.
NOT JUST THE FAILURES OF THE
PAST BUT FROM NEW YORK TO
CALIFORNIA IN PENNSYLVANIA
BOLDER AND BRAVER AND THAT IS
"THE NEXT REVOLUTION" THAT WE